what's up guys I'm Greg Alba and I'm
John Humphrey we're gonna review Pet
Sematary today the latest adaptation
from Stephen King I guess I'm mediocre
ly excited to talk about this movie hey
before we go into this why don't you
guys go ahead and download and follow us
on the stardust app thank you to
everyone who has done so thus far over
there we do thirty second reaction
reviews for any film TV show or trailer
sometimes we do micro sketches if you
want to get our opinion first before
even our YouTube review is out or for
movies we don't even talk about our
YouTube it'd be cool if you followed us
there and you could post your own
reactions reviews as well so do that
today
I don't him on a pet sematary this movie
is a an adaptation more so than anything
else I know there was a movie a couple
decades ago or something like that but I
heard the directors did not really want
to go approaching this as a remake they
wanted to just go to the source material
which I feel like is the smartest way to
actually approach a second go around
when you're adapting a book and why so
many people say that when they're
redoing a Stephen King yeah exactly it's
a common thing to say right ago
you know what just to make my life a lot
easier I'm just gonna read the IMDB
description dr. Lewis Creed played by
Jason Clarke and his wife Rachel played
by Amy seimetz that's a cool name
relocate from Boston to rural Maine with
her two young children the couple soon
discover mysterious burial ground hidden
deep in the woods near their home to
elaborate a little bit more that burial
ground you bury something dead it comes
back to life and it behaves like Stewie
when he creates a clone of himself roll
that clip yeah yeah there's actually
like a surprising amount of hype going
into this I mean today when we're
filming this that like the Rotten
Tomatoes scores down to like 61% or
something like that right before we saw
this that there was all this like
twitter blowing up about a pet
cemeteries it's great horror film and
then Rotten Tomatoes score was even
really really high we kind of went into
this expecting something pretty cool I
think both of us and actually people we
talked to who we didn't even know we're
gonna be there when the movie was done
were like yeah it's fine it was good
yeah and then that was kind of a we
reaction to have just because I think
that out of all the Stephen King stories
that have been made into movies
previously this is one that could use an
update because while the original Pet
Sematary does have parts that are still
chilling and scary there are also parts
that are kind of dated and cheesy and so
I feel like this one as opposed to a
shining or something else does lend
itself to a remake so I went in actually
pretty excited to see what would happen
and yeah ultimately I came out with like
a pretty good yeah yeah see for me I'd
never read the book and honestly I I'm
not even sure I saw the other movie I
saw the trailer for it and and I was
looking at that trailer going I think
I've seen this movie I don't remember so
watching the film this this 2019 edition
there wasn't a single moment who are
watching it where my mind would flash
you go oh like in the original movie
that never happened for me so I was able
to just view this on its own merits
without having any prior knowledge other
than the two trailers that Paramount
Pictures reliving they released more but
the two main trailers the trailer is
kind of ruin of a lot you give away a
lot of significant events yes we're
gonna take the reins to talk about
things that the two main trailers that
would play in the movie theaters to talk
about those plot points specifically we
won't talk about the ending because that
would be a major spoiler that don't show
in the trailer and even though we feel
the trailers to spoil a lot better about
pictures released it so yeah we'll talk
about it if you have been like very anal
about avoiding all trailers you don't
want to know anything and you didn't see
the the original movie or whatever or
you read the book you might want to skip
this non-spoiler review because we're
going off of what the trailers provided
for us okay this really kind of feels
like two halves to me that were met
halfway yeah
the first half of this movie you know
like the families relocated and they're
trying to settle into the countryside of
where they're living at you got a
husband a wife and a daughter and like a
baby boy right and they have a neighbor
played by John Lithgow named Judd so in
the first half of this movie you got a
story that is dealing with it with a
kind of a variety of things but one
the elements is you got a creepy cat
okay and then the second half of the
story which I'm pretty surprised that
the trailer reveals I am and I'm not I
get why they did it but also yeah it's a
pretty blatant spoil because it happens
like halfway through the movie or maybe
a little bit past halfway through the
daughter dies and then eventually they
bring her back using whatever
supernatural abilities Pet Sematary
offers she comes back as a creepy evil
girl you got these two halves and I sort
of feel like this movie could have
really benefited from an additional 20
to 30 minutes
a lot of certain sequences and moments
or just emotional effect could have
really benefited off of having some real
build to there or some better
exploration into a lot of its elements
for example with the daughter this is
just one example I'm gonna give you guys
a lot of this movie has moments that I
find creepy moments that were scary
moments let me go whoa but I've never
really find any scenes to make me feel
that way in order to find any scenes
that really had me emotionally gripped
yeah and it seems and it's very apparent
the movie is aiming for that and a lot
of scenes they're definitely aiming for
that because I think this movie really
wants to be and in borrows tonally from
a lot of the more recent films that are
about you know people consumed with
grief yeah and the persona 4
yeah babadook hereditary yeah it seems
like it's trying to meet this halfway
point of being more of like art house
horror like hereditary and babadook and
then being studio horror like Stephen
King's it you know it seems like it's
trying to blend both a little bit the
story doesn't lend itself to that I mean
I know Stephen King's books have those
elements of very personal and and very
you know mental exploration basically
there are a lot of themes in those and
they pop up here but I really did feel
like yeah the film itself could have
used just a different distribution of
time and focus or maybe a little extra
time because the the beginning
especially and the finale or the third
act really did feel kind of clipped and
I also felt like a lot of the dialogue
was
left to be very kind of on the nose for
a lot of the movie yeah you know in just
a way where if they had added some extra
flavor to it it could have felt a lot
more lived-in yeah because it's like
everything's doing its job technically
that's why I was like this really meets
the fine good level of your potential
for a lot of this to be great was always
there and the example I wanted to bring
up was with the daughter because when
she comes back to life the the biggest
issue I had with that whole the wall the
way the whole thing plays out I mean
yeah there's some like pretty dumb
choices that some characters make in
this movie that I don't feel are well
justified just because a character
brings up that that was a bad choice so
the whole thing with dad with the
distribution of events and the way
things build or don't necessarily it
doesn't help those moments feel any more
human or any more you know
understandable yeah it's like if this
movie had a tone that was a little bit
more self-aware of what it was kind of
like how it did that then it probably
would have benefited for answer like
forgiveness of some illogical choices or
if the dialogue had some more nuance in
it anyway the point I've been spending
three minutes trying to get to is with
the daughter when she comes back it
really could have benefited from some
breathing room of the time when she's
brought back to life instead of it going
oh yeah oh she's definitely like an evil
creep you know like right away evil
creep I think it really could have
benefited if Jason Clarke had this
relationship with her where even if us
is the audience knows that she's gonna
be like a little twisted and [ __ ] up
we we know that it really would have
benefited the movie on the emotional
journey if there was a couple of scenes
or even one scene that they really let
play out where Jason Clarke you
logically see him going oh maybe she's
normal maybe she's fine maybe I
successfully did this and it's okay well
yeah because the movie chooses to follow
him as the protagonist and early on they
establish him as a guy who does not
believe in an afterlife he is a very
skeptic you know logical person he's a
doctor of science in a certain sense is
our avatar and I feel like they really
ought to have yeah convinced us by
convincing him exactly cuz that would
have been really important because
otherwise we're left to sit here going
do this is a terrible idea and you
should have known
yeah yeah I think the acting in this
movie is great I think the acting in
this movie is better than the writing at
the dialogue like Jason Clark is is
wonderful in the film amy seimetz who
plays the wife / mother who has a really
traumatic past with her deceased sister
Zelda who suffer from a spinal condition
the kids are fine John Lithgow you know
obviously he's gonna be great John
Lithgow the actors are wonderful but
then I kind of see a different issue
that sort of takes place where the real
intriguing character here is the wife I
really wish she was the lead like she
has the interesting backstory she had
this the the setup for the arc her
elements were definitely more of an
interesting character than anyone else
in this film and if you're doing that
you know a second shot or remake well
she's clearly the more interesting
character yeah what I truly at least
after having just seen feminists first
just being progressive I only think
that's yeah I actually believe we don't
actually believe it we're just trying to
stand up for what's right yeah I think
it would I think it would have been cool
to see her as the protagonist or even
see something where Jason Clark starts
as the protagonist and around the time
grace is the daughter it switches yeah
yeah gives us something a little more
than this is just a really bad situation
like for everybody a lot a lot of the
moments that I feel that could have been
effective should have been a little bit
more layered with more specific internal
conflicts you know that requires like
spoiler territory for a lot of things
you know like especially when the mom
sees that her daughter's brought back to
life it just sort of becomes an instant
like no this thing's evil
well like if your daughter's dead and
she comes back to life I feel like there
should be some real conflict at present
of like holy [ __ ] I've been missing you
and I mean I do like that scene but
ultimately as a part of a greater whole
that is the movie I can't quite put my
finger on it but there is something in
the focus this movie has or what it
chooses to put its weight on that yeah
doesn't really pay everything off for me
and the other issue I really have with
it is it feels like it wants to be
deeper than what it is but the movies
just not as clever as I feel like it
needs to actually be sure there's some
creepy moments yeah is the acting good
is the structure of the script fine yeah
but the movie never got clever for me it
was it was rather predictable its er
pretty like other than the final moments
I'm talking like the last two minutes of
this movie like the last two minutes
everything was pretty much by the
numbers and exactly how you expect all
this to play out it doesn't feel as deep
or fleshed out as it could have been
because there's a lot of things set up
with our characters there's a lot of
theme set up about faith with our
characters that never really have a
payoff and there's this whole other
story line that deals with the death of
this kid who's haunting Jason Clark
someone who's like it's very early on in
the movie who had this death of this kid
he's haunting Jason Clark throughout the
movie it's never really quite explained
the rules of the kid of the ghosts or
whatever it like it's never really it's
kind of confusing when you look back on
it like wait what's the deal with you
know what is Karen and why is why
appearing to other people now you know
yeah there's no real payoffs or
conclusions I'm sure there's something
to that but at least again my experience
with this movie it did seem a bit random
and a bit yeah wait hold on what and and
even the stuff with zelda the sister
kind of feels grafted on well that could
have been a great payoff yeah yeah
there's a lot of things that are set up
for really good payoff yeah and it's
like you want them to unpack it but you
mostly just get the The effect of it you
mostly get it like oh this is traumatic
okay I get it but let's unpack this it's
like I know that some people might hear
that and go wait a minute you got a prom
with the expositional dialogue yet
you're upset with not fully unpacking
I'm like well that's the thing though is
if you especially if you're your first
half if you have so much expositional
dialog you should definitely have a good
payoff for a lot of these things and
when by the end of it and when the
exposition is stuff like they've just
moved into their new house and are
talking about why they just moved into
their new house and I'm like I bet you
guys already in a real life what I had
this yeah there's a lot of those
conversations yeah again yeah and some
moments like that you're like I wish
we'd chosen just a whole different
palette of things here that could have
developed the characters and helped this
out yeah yeah so is there some cool
cinematography sure there's some cool
creepy like like we say at the beginning
this movie's fine it's better than a lot
of horror movies that come out solid
remake yeah yeah and a solid blockbuster
remake I guess
the reason why we complain about it is
because you could feel that there's a
great movie that could have been made
here yeah there's like a great cut of
this it's for someone who doesn't know
the source material who doesn't even
remember the other movie is just
watching this I couldn't help but watch
so much of this movie and go it's it's
close it's just fine I don't know why
I'm not as excited as a lot of people
are and I was really excited going into
this movie because I thought that
especially seeing the trailer on the big
screen I thought it packed a lot of that
Menace and I thought a lot of the Menace
kind of dissipated throughout the movie
as you know you've got this really thick
second act there's a lot of suspense
sequences and I've seen a lot of
suspense sequences in a lot of movies
lately and and yeah go rent starry eyes
because if you want to see what these
two dudes can do on like a punch
level go watch that two and a half three
stars at five or something like a three
you know maybe three and a half I'm
feeling generous did you see Pet
Sematary did you love it
what do you disagree with us about what
do you agree with us about leave it in
the comments below and follow us in the
Stardust app you guys can also subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification bell and we'll catch you
guys soon